DOES THINGS OTHER GUYS JUST  IN
CAN'T.
THE WAY HE SENT THE , THE PLAYS
.  VLADAR HAS GOT THAT AS WELL.
TERRIFIC PUCK MOVEMENT
RADDYSH, JOSEPH, LOOKS
COMFORTABLE OUT THERE.
>> TAMPA BAY HAS HIT THE POST .
BLOCKED BY ANDERSSON..  LINE
CHANGE TOO.
IN THE SECOND PERIOD, YOU GET
FIRES AND ANOTHER SHOT BLOCKED
BY THE FLAMES.
>> Brian: HE WAS TRYING TO BE
AFTER KUCHEROV  FOUND THE POSTD
FOR AN ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
SHOT BY BELLEMARE?. HE HAS REAL
HIS SCORING.
THAT ISIS
ABOUT EARLIER.
LOTS OF TIME TO WORK WITH . STA
CIRCLE.
DOWNLOAD CERNAK . CERNAK
CAN'T GET THE SHOT AWAY.
KNEW WHERE POINT WAS ALL ALONG.
DOWN. FOR IT
AGAINST TREVOR LEWIS . KUCHEROV
SCORES!
HE IS THE ONE THAT CREATES THIS
AND STAYS WITH IT.
WATCH THIS MOVE.
BACK?
WOW.
UNREAL.VERY MUCH. TEAMS.
THEY ARE SET TO MEET AGAIN IN
EARLY MARCH IN CALGARY. MES.
SODAS PALAT  AND PERRY.
THIS ONE IS CUT
>> Brian: HELD UP
DEFLECTED BY FOOTE.
DUBE